find out let's welcome Ray
[Applause]
Romano
yeah the living Queen so easy for me to
be here thank you that Mory guy sounds
too much like
me know all right how why are you at the
greatest concert ever I got to ask uh my
manager Ro Rose Garden told
me only I like the Rory Rose Garden
reference I'm trying to Branch out you
know so we just did Ice Age
to right
yeah are those sarcastic claps it's a
good film Dennis ly
uh promoting the ice h 2 ice H1 is on
Blu-ray and uh
season 9 also what about you coming out
here and singing what's going on well uh
I have a lot of free time twin boys a
lovely family I played Carnegie Hall but
I have a lot of free time now and uh
music is H the universal language so all
right well what you got for us tonight
got to play a
song I guess we'll find
[Applause]
out you want to pick yeah
I don't have a
strap I'm I'm a comedian I don't do
this it's hard for me you can use this
one but I don't know if you're used to
it weird I can only sing in one
key my twin boys told me this was a good
one so I don't like you moving over
there I was trying not to take Focus but
uh you fix that thought you were Todd
[Laughter]
marry oh
yeah all
[Music]
right somebody's
hiding in my ice box somebody's
C CHS closey Ice
Bar season n
[Applause]
Blu-ray my
eyes oh
yeah oh
right feels really really
girl
inside should a St
CRA millions and millions of
dollars season a also BL right F on
J wrestle with
Jimmy some
B and behind my
back is
ready
break
saying so w your drug is a life
[Music]
taker saying so oh wow you're
love season two on Blu
Ray Dear Daddy I'll write you in spite
of years of Silence you cleaned up found
hos things are good oh so I hear this
bottle of Stevens awakens ancient
feelings like Father step far the blood
is drowning in the
Sun
season 3 is also
available is a live
maker say
so feel like this peak about 45
seconds
thank
you everybody Loves Raymond but not as
much as the lord loves all of
you and you will bow down before the
King of
[Applause]
Queens I thought he was great good songs
good town great rock and
roll what the [__] is
Blu-ray
well Blu-ray it makes everything better
it makes that show funnier I guess on
Blu-ray can see it
better Blu-rays when he pulls his dick
out oh all
right it's a good one
Johnny